hello ladies and gentlemen my name is
Ryan the right I am Dan the cyber yes
dan is here he's my co-host today not a
female first time having a male and
everyone's left no everyone's yeah the
views of Gandhi oh oh the dislike what
an interesting dan will be presenting
the items as we unbox super geek box
December 2015 good times good they have
that's the thing let's do this dance
star for the first item I'll try to go
smallest to biggest mostly there's a pin
in there if there's a pin in there
reveal the pin first it's never exciting
when it's like the fourth or fifth item
start with a pin if there's a pen I'm
gonna go find a pen I found a pin start
with a pin pin others Deadpool Finn and
Jake nice I'd love it's Christmas Eve
it's Christmassy ya see that here let me
focus it for you oh yeah there you go
sweet roll focus bro I don't know if
it's so bright yeah now we'll stay how
to focus the whole video for you guys
next time I'm day okay okay you're
really gonna like this one I'm really
gonna like this yeah you could have just
looked but it's fine no I know it's a
tiny little adorn are getting bad oh
that's so cool and creepy at the same
time it's a voodoo Batman it's a voodoo
Batman Batman and the Batman even the
bats upside down see this is creepy it
looks like a cat came to life and turn
into Batman Oh your cats are gonna love
a cat man this is pretty cool I love it
it's like good it's creepy it's like
Arkham Asylum style which we got damn
it's blah oh is that a [ __ ] adventure
time fan yeah they actually want to work
with me on something I she gets another
show yeah you should what the [ __ ] yeah
adventure time finn yeah possible deal
in the works people that's what's in the
ball what do the ball good thing I have
this knife here good thing I notice
everything about these unboxing videos
you always need a knife around you never
know what's gonna be wrapped too tight
ha tight I got a giant yep got
oh you wouldn't together and he's got a
giant head yeah oh that's cool that's
smart do you watch a venture time yeah
do you love adventure time I really like
about you come then Merry Christmas dad
that's for you thank you you that's for
you or to put it to go I'm giving away
stuff this holiday season okay thank you
i unboxed to give you just like
regifting I get it yeah yeah it's for
your presents for this year Thank You
1up box and super deep box so the
brand's gonna love your vegetable yeah
here you go they make for great gifts
did you write here you go excellent oh
sweet coexist yeah oh that's so neat
they got the death star of the pokeball
that efore everyone rating lightsabers
and what's these others great that's the
TARDIS flash and Mullen or wash yeah the
white the TARDIS the tortoise what's its
hardest Doctor Who right you watch
Doctor Who then next one okay next thing
this socks yay Oh of to the flower hey
what's the let's see exactly with that
lacuna the Kudo oh yeah should be enemy
critters I'm not wearing socks right now
oh oh this is this is a live soft
reaction of livestock reaction whoa sock
reaction yep well looks like they got
good stretch in there good arc support
yeah not like the Batman ones your
girlfriend bought me those socks take at
least 10 minutes to put on not my fault
not my fault that oh there you go how
you feel good comfortable ooh can't can
can't admit that his feet do not smell
right now well they're brand new socks
all right I got well with students next
ready boom nice i got it Deadpool I
wanted one oh they know what's in this
holiday season
yeah hey yes that's really [ __ ] cool
so it's the best gifts right here so far
thus far okay that's far yeah Michael
evola shirts appear you go oh oh I'm not
giving this one away are no wrong with
this one that's too good hold on peeps
about a brand them up barrel down where
we doing huh being on the shirt back
yeah what are you talking about we're
making a partner it out that's how I
came out of my mom's vagina was like
that ha ha life is I promote the item
doing the Shibuya riot oh let's see if
it's his so bad i was i was two feet
tall yeah all right okay yeah d string
right here Dan you hold that home it
thumbnail time
anyway guys listen listen if you want to
get a super geek box so will not benefit
me in any way you should go to the
description link at the top there's a
referral link i put there if you want
one please get it through the referral
II don't just go to their website and
buy it go through the referral link you
can you're gonna want to hit that real
reject referral rig yeah we're full rank
3 I just don't worry about it he
subscribed to the real rejects do that
Dan's gaming channel right here that
cyber channel check it out as soon as
possible yes it's best not to wait on
those sort of things wanna give a shout
out to Mel Gibson I forgive you oh I
forgive you you're working machete kills
was mesmerizing well now I feel better
about life well now I feel better about
life is it kosher